I'm Marcus John's with Fandango and we
are here at the 2015 Oscars and we are
about to have some fun what are we doing
we never know with me but we're gonna
find out
we are absolutely walking down something
we should not be walking down right now
this from pouring and casting all the
chocolate it took us a solid probably a
week so this food what you're telling me
is a week old can I wear my people hey
that was cool
they're just making me feel real nice
about myself right there some
predictions for who's gonna stop by
we're gonna have the entire cast of
boyhood stop one second one second 30
seconds 30 seconds 15 seconds he gives
me a nod he says awkward on screen as he
is in real life and I'm just kidding no
but really though who else is gonna stop
by us Wes Anderson himself he's gonna
take the camera and say mark let's go
film a movie together west west once one
second just a selfie I want just no
thank you sir I appreciate it what a
kind gentleman the stars are walking
through let's do this Zoe Zoe just a
selfie real quick yes ready you are the
hottest girl in the galaxy thank you so
much oh my god yeah I just want to say
congrats all your success do you mind
saying hi to Fandango let's go friend oh
yeah I selfie you ready okay there you
go ready
swag
thank thank you so much I appreciate it
John I'm just an ordinary person can I
get a selfie okay I have no idea what's
going on with fashion right now I'm just
I'm just gonna take a wild stab and say
she's killing it okay are you gonna
actually come back Scarlett Scarlett can
I just have a picture just a selfie
Scarlett's what are you doing to me just
a picture just a picture
Benny Rosman you said you were gonna
stop you said you were gonna stop oh
she's a darn liar you win some you lose
some
really I'm Heidi's the morgue until them
direct relationship why weren't you
casted as the third Weasley brother in
the Harry Potter series I don't know
would you rather have fingers the size
of your legs or legs the size of your
finger Oh long fingers long fingers all
right we're about to give a fake award
out in a minute
congratulations on being nominated for
best time oh my god yes you did the
slowest red carpet walk and the award
goes to pink scarf lady what is it like
to create the most addictive song on the
planet everything is going you're part
of the team hey Fandango how are you
doing I was thinking
hi Fandango how you doing oh this is
when I start screaming at celebs thank
you so much Glenn I appreciate it oh
then we have another nominee for the
slowest Walker award looking a tad
faster than the other one do you mind if
I just grab a quick picture with you
thank you he's the most active dinosaur
I've ever seen my oh my girl Athena
Lapita I took a selfie with you last
year last year girl you ain't gonna win
nothing this year after that Oh Jennifer
that dress Jennifer oh my god you're so
tall Jennifer my pen take oh how you
doing it just one more time for good
measure
hey mango how you doing guys we had so
much fun at the 2015 Oscars with Ben
Dingle we had a bunch of people stop by
I've got a lot of selfies it was amazing
we talked to a lot of crazy famous
celebs it was awesome until next time
i'm marga stylist Fandango see you guys